your past week was supposed to look
really different you were supposed to be
inducted into the Canadian Music Hall of
Fame and the Juno uh so how do you feel
about all that I'm fine you know not I
don't ever want to sound unappreciative
or but I am not really an awardee person
when Alan Reed told me that I was going
to be inducted um I I started to cry
because it's it's a scary thing for me
I'm thinking God how much time has gone
by and of course I was excited to see ad
Maria and I become friends really over
the last 20 years and she's retired I
don't see her as much as I used to when
we were both you know working and so and
yeah I was looking forward to seeing
that and to seeing her and what she was
gonna say and things like that I can't
lie
but I'm so fine I was one of the very
early people in the Juneau path
communicating with my office Bruce Allen
communicating with you know Alan Reed
and just saying I don't think we can put
this on and it was we were just on the
edge of the cliff at that time there was
no cases in Saskatchewan at that time
and of course Saskatoon's excited you
worry about a peep a group of people
that have been working so hard for a
year but I think they also realized it's
not just that group of people it's the
entire 39 million citizens of Canada
that have all been working on projects
and all in doing things so I thought
anything when any you know I think this
year we are really actively I know the
Juneau committee is actively working on
getting these statues to the people I
mean imagine being nominated for the
first time I like for you know vocalist
or single their song or album a writer
or they are really working on how that's
going to look once again utilizing
technology they're trying to figure out
how to give the awards out so that's
gonna happen I think the show itself
it's done for this year it's not going
to be there money there might be some
kind of weird online configuration where
we can at least announce the winners
get the trophies out but next year is
the 50th anniversary of the Juno Awards
so there'll be an extra reason to
celebrate and I'd very much will rally
very hard for me to have my moment with
an I'm gonna say this and I don't give a
crap what you guys do this year I want
Ann Marie to hug me and give me my damn
trophy so don't don't worry Cheryl I'm
gonna be working hard on that I want to
see that I definitely all want to see
that have you been talking to Ann how's
she doing he's doing good she's making
her way back to she might be home
already she might be back in or she
lives in Halifax now you were getting
ready to do a huge cross-country tour
this year yeah what's the discussion on
that how are you we nothing nothing has
happened yet I I personally I have no
idea what the next six weeks is gonna
look like I don't start until May June I
feel like that will be picked up and
moved but you know people will get their
money back or we will announce right now
it hasn't that hasn't happened and I
think people were so inundated with
things that the decision that my office
is made for the time being is to get
settled into the next two or three weeks
and then make those decisions
what about time your show I was that
coming along what's the latest with that
I'm hoping that the release date it's
all finished it's all in the can
it was slated to kind of go bay and
we're all hoping that we kind of slide
that thing a bit forward I think people
really need comedy content um so yeah
it's so funny season two we're actually
like shooting ideas around for season
three already so the reason I've been
doing you know online programs and
talking about storyboard ideas and
things like that but um I actually
watched all eight finished episodes
yesterday and I really laughed cuz I
don't remember any of the dialogue soon
as I learn lines they're gone
thank you I'm not an actor
like I'm not a trained actor I don't
know how they do it but you're me I
learn it and then it's God I my hardware
does not work that way I feel
overwhelmed yeah so I was watching it
like I can't even remember saying this I
don't even remember doing I look to you
although getting older has its benefit
has its perks
right definitely look yet I want you to
know that while at home here I have
written a song and I was hoping you
could put some music to it for me
are you ready you don't if you don't
okay I'm ready it's a kid's song if that
gets stuck in my head
call me tonight I will be tapping on
your window we're gonna watch I know
it's a jingle for parents we're doing a
service but it's gonna be an earworm and
you're welcome I think it's very good I
think it's very very good if you don't
if you're not nominated for a Juno next
year then then there's no justice in the
world